This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English. I'm Neil.
Hello, I'm Catherine.
And if I say to you, Catherine, Fortnite, what do you think of?
Well, that's easy, Neil. A Fortnite is a period of two weeks.
Well, Fortnite, spelt F-O-R-T-N-I-G-H-T, is indeed a period of two weeks.
But Fortnite, spelt F-O-R-T-N-I-T-E, is an online computer game that has become
incredibly popular in a very short period of time.
As well as popular, it's also very competitive.
And you're soon going to be able to make big money playing it,
and you can even hire people to be your Fortnite coach.
Well, before we hear a little more about this topic, it's time for our quiz.
These days, we play computer games on our phones.
We can hold them in our hands.
In 1950, Bertie the Brain was the name of one of the very first computer games.
It played a simple game of knots and crosses, also called Tic-Tac-Toe.
But how tall was this computer?
Was it A, 1 meter tall?
B, about 4 meters tall?
Or C, about 10 meters tall?
Well, if it was a 1950s, computers were huge.
So I'm going to go for 10 meters.
Okay, well, we'll find out if you're right at the end of the program.
Esports or computer games competitions are now a thing.
In some markets, they are huge and they are even discussing including them in the Olympic games.
Kyle Jackson is a 13 year old gamer who's been asked to join a team.
How long does he say he's been playing video games?
Play video games all my life, basically.
I started playing competitively when I was around 9 or 10.
I got into Halo, Call of Duty, games like that.
And I just, I realised that I could probably go to a pro level if I keep playing at the level I am.
He said that he's been playing computer games all his life.
Now that might be a little exaggeration,
but he's probably been playing them ever since he can remember.
When he was 9 or 10, he started playing competitively,
which means he started playing in competitions against other people.
He talks about a number of games that he got into.
This is a good expression.
If you're into something, you are very interested in it.
And to get into something,
describes the process of becoming interested in that thing.
In Kyle's case, it was computer games,
and he got so good that he's thinking about playing at a professional level.
Doing something as a professional means that it's more than a hobby or pastime.
It's something someone pays you to do because you're really good at it.
George Yao is a former gaming champion who is now director of media of team secret.
Team secret are like a regular sports team.
They have a group of players who play matches and competitions against other teams,
except these are not regular sports.
These are e-sports and they are big business.
Here's George Yao.
It's becoming a multi-billion dollar industry.
Just games, production of games, publishing of games, and the esports scene.
So it's not just one thing now.
It's a whole industry.
So George Yao says that online gaming is becoming a multi-billion dollar industry.
We usually think of industry as factories and manufacturing,
but it can also apply to other areas as well
that involve a lot of different elements that come together to make a business.
Different elements that he mentions as part of this industry are creating games,
publishing games, and the esports scene.
The word scene here refers to the world of esports,
the events, the competitions, and the players,
and many people want to be part of that scene.
Right now, let's get the answer to our quiz question
about the size of that 1950s computer game.
Was it A, one meter tall, B, four meters tall, or C, 10 meters tall?
What did you say, Catherine?
I went for 10 meters, Neil.
Well, unfortunately, it was four meters.
Still quite big, though. Imagine you couldn't get one of those in your pocket.
Rather not.
But I would like to review today's vocabulary.
We started off with the word for a period of two weeks, a fortnight.
But with a different spelling,
fortnight is also a very popular video game.
Multi-player video game competitions,
which people pay to go and watch are known as esports.
Playing against other people is playing competitively.
Do you like to play multi-player video games, Catherine?
I've never really got into them, even though I've tried one or two.
And that was one of our other expressions to get into something,
to become really interested in something.
Same here. I enjoy playing a little bit,
but I could never be a professional.
I couldn't get paid to do it as a job.
Of course not. You're already a professional, broadcaster, Neil.
An area of business that's made up of different parts
can be described as an industry.
The video game industry is a multi-billion dollar business.
And we also talk about, for example,
the fashion industry and the movie industry.
And finally, there was the word scene.
This noun is used to describe the world of a particular activity.
So the esport scene, for example, is the world of esports.
The games, the teams, the competition, the audiences,
it's all part of this scene.
Well, that's all from the six-minute English scene today.
Do join us again, but if you can't wait,
you can find us on Facebook, Twitter, Instagram, and YouTube.
And of course, on our website,
BBCLearningEnglish.com.
Thanks for joining us and goodbye.
Goodbye.